[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
just
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
uh
[Music]
two
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
we have a great excitement in sns and
how are you enjoying this this is
today's emcee ichiro mori
and also we have
assistance
i am nashiko momosuki nice to see
and actually from this afternoon today
the general public will enter this venue
so this is the first time in three years
or two years so this is the third year
so do you have any specific memories of
tokyo game show so even before getting
into this industry i was a
costume player so i joined this game
show or some of my friends are and
costume players and they join the tokyo
game show so
actually i really enjoy costume praying
and also the game show
since i was young
and also
i can see the costume players of the
games and this game show so now this
reminds me of how i was enjoying the
game show so from tomorrow you can see
more so also what do you think yes this
is a
first time in three years to have such a
real
actual game show
so we can see
how many people are enjoying the stage
and then
again i'm very looking forward to see
tomorrow
yes so everybody is looking for that and
then from tomorrow we're going to have
the general fabric day and i'd like to
show you how you can enjoy
the on-site
just before the opening i have come to
this konami booth
so please see that how spacious it is
that's great and i'm so excited to see
you here
and also there are lots of titles in the
booth so please stay tuned
now i'm going to show you around
first on the right side of the booth
this is the ugo
in each corner
if you play the game you can get the
official card game they call the poker
and also for the yu-gi-oh rush corner
you can get rush dual secret ace pack
vol 3 additionally
now this is the yukio crosstalk corner
on the other day is that the
distribution and then the cross jewel
is a little different from the card game
so actually four players can join the
match so this is a new sense of gaming
digital card gaming on a real-time basis
you can play the match and also you have
to look at the situation of the
battle and also you can enjoy the
wheeling and the dealing and all the
monsters are appearing in 3d
so you can enjoy their performance and
also the
characters from the seven animation
series of ugo would appear
so you can see the familiar characters
in this game as well
and then on site you can enjoy both
players much so you have not experienced
yet please try it
and next
is
yugioh master jewel which is already
being distributed and the global tourist
members will join this
so you can enjoy this game anywhere and
anytime that's the purpose of this game
and with the latest
console you can enjoy the sound and the
4k
definition graphics so that's a very
powerful picture
and then please see this gaming chair
your master jewel can be experienced
here on site
the solar mode is newly released so if
you are interested in there or if you
have not experienced it yet please try
it
and the third one
you
in this area the global tourists will
join here so you can do the duel with
them
so in this venue you can see the large
monitors and the decks are designed to
be in line with the image image of the
dualists
and the last one
which will be
launched in this winter
the ugo's strongest but royal
er
gold rush which will be played by
nintendo switch
so an animation
broadcasted by tokyo's
broadcasting this animation that this
game is related with so you can enjoy
the yo go rush and then you can get more
excitement and act anywhere at any time
you can play with them
for the card games and if you join this
game you can get the they called the
poker and also your rush duo secret s
pack vol 3.
so
endless if you experience any of them
you can get the cars which are the
limited version for this site so let's
play it that's all from for the yu-gi-oh
area from the booth
so now i have this secret
ace pack
five cars and this they could
shine
so for the secret pack there are five
types
so all of these five could be the same
but nobody knows which one is which so
you don't know
of course
you can guess but just for review
this one
i got this
it's shining again
it's very shiny i cannot read the name
of the card
so you can get
this one
if you experience a game in our booth
and also lots of information is here
horizon yes so one of the information is
here
tomorrow september 17th saturday where
you're going to have the yu-gi-oh
crosstalk teach you a special duel on
the stage joined by enakosa mr shachiko
morimoto
from yonsei
so nasco you are very looking forward to
seeing that right yes all of them are
very strong so it's very difficult to
make a guess who will winner
so all of them are winning jurors as for
anna kosan
so
is she your junior colleague or senior
colleague
has a long history of a close team
player and we both were from aichi
prefecture so personally i loved her
so also you can
[Music]
look forward to it and also if you make
a correct guess of the winner you can
get the paper phone autographed by
anako-san so this is the sns campaign so
please take a look at the your crosstalk
official twitter for more information
and also
[Music]
we have a newly created
crustal video clip which was distributed
on site so please take a look
cross four players
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
monsters
[Music]
for spill cars
[Music]
frost cars
[Music]
plus team
[Music]
crossfade
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cross emotion
cross
cross everyone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's the crosstrail
so even if you don't know the rules you
can
play it casually is that right nashville
yes card game is 101 battle in many
cases but for this four players may join
so it's very fresh so how to battle
i was just wondering and
i so just watching that mv
i really want to try it so you can start
it right away that's the one of the
advantage of that yes so even a beginner
can play it
yes even if you don't know about the
rules you can join that
and next one is uni dual rings today
and a new world was added that was
announcements for september 28th and
then we're going to have a campaign from
28th and also the talk show will be
streamed and you can so please access
your ocg channel and also i have a new
world released
so it's still going
and then on december 1st where
we're going to have the new rush duo
strongest battle royal royal garage
which will be launched on december 1st
but for me this week so i'm going to
show you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you have more information right yes i
have just explained
this one
this is the in addition to the free to
play standard edition
we're going to have the special edition
including
each type starting from the place
playing
and also
the three cars with the limited
promotion card will be included in a
special edition of the first production
and which is greased storm revolution
build carrier
big storm however in the first
production version
of the special edition if you have the
hit number
uh which means one or one thousand
winners you can get the blue eyes white
dragon of rush duel so 1 000 people
so what's the probability yes
and then this is a fiscal version
information on november 26 saturday the
new product of the rush duel over rush
park will go on sale so this is the
illustration the illustration is going
beyond the frame so it's a very rare
reality over russian layer
so i want to show you how it's shining
so i'm going to show you this video
it's rare for us to see such a case so
actually no sound no voice but car is
shining yes we are so excited
great impression and that would come up
yes
yes and today i'm going to release a new
information
as a
special offer for early reservation
marijuana you can get the
red eyes black dragon over russia rare
of your rush model
so
if you have already
made a reservation if so of course you
can get this special offer
mamutsuki-san so i have shown lots of
information here what do you think about
that that's great and that shiny card is
very fresh my memory so i want to have
all of these
three shining cards
so what what about draw it depends
it depends on the item and the days so
sometimes we can get a good one however
if you spend more you can get more
results
next
so the next one is super
bomberman r2 there are a lot of
information please enjoy
so in this area you can
enjoy super bomberman r2 with four
players
if you play the game and you will get
get this eco-friendly bag
but the number is limited so please
visit early
in this
area you can play the game against
comedians and you can watch the live
playing
please come and visit the booth
thank you it was about super bomberman
r2 and we have the video to show you so
please enjoy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
that's the game that plays among four
people
so i don't know know about the castle
mode what is it the castle mode is the
the new mode for super bomberman r2
asymmetrical and you play offense for
defense and you get the territory so
this is the new type of bomberman
and the comedians are going to play the
game yes
tomorrow at the venue from 2 10 p.m on
saturday the comedians are going to play
the game
yes
i want him to
get relieved
and now we are going to
introduce anime famous game in a corner
where you can
talk to the girls band
there's more to come for konami booth
the famous anime and popular anime idol
project shy imposed there's a mobile
game called shine post be your idol
you can choose your favorite characters
and you can take a picture with the
idols and you can enjoy the costume
novel music live music dance animation
so you can enjoy all of these only here
at the booth
and also that is the uh the game that is
being developed and only at the venue
you can watch the video
now let's take a look what kind of
pictures you can take
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please follow official twitter account
of shine post
and please participate in a picture
taken event and you will get original
rubber band
near the booth you will get this
japanese style fan
so we will wait for you at the venue
and next to the shine post we have the
corner for genso suikoden
just today 3 30 pm the information was
out
the gen socie codenda was out
with playstation in 1995. after 27 years
now the game social one and two hd
remaster
gate roon and doonan unification wars
will be released
playstation 4 xbox one and steam and
nintendo switch
with this you can play it and the game
is going to be released in 2023
in this corner
you can play the dice game you know that
ice game if you have played against
godan right
so
based on the result of the dice game you
will get cancelled and one and two hd
remaster trading cam badge
you can
play the dice game with the characters
you and based on the result of the dice
game you will get a many cam badge
and
you will get that you will see the
original picture
and please come and take a picture and
post your memory on twitter
next to again so secretary we have a
corner for hinavita
there's a key visual
that commemorates ten year anniversary
so there are panels of seven characters
can take a picture
so please come and take a picture
and also
the cam badge is
has come back
where it was
it was distributed in city of karashi
and please use the hashtag and post it
and you can get it and this the number
is limited so please don't miss it so i
introduced three titles from konami
[Music]
i loved it so taking pictures with a
character
you know it's usually nothing special
but watching a video you know the
characters are surrounding
you and they strike a pose and there's a
group picture
and this is what you experience when you
see idol
you never imagine you can do that with
the 2d characters and i got really
excited
and you have additional information
right oh it's done yes
and there's a new
game video you can watch at the venue
and also 3 p.m on sunday
there will be the talk show among
solutions
and the new characters and special
guests
uh will also appear there will be a talk
show so please enjoy
and again
one and two htv master please talk about
it
please watch the video first
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i made a request and we have
another video so this is a video from
the beginning of the game this is very
special
please watch
[Music]
do
[Music]
hd remaster
so it is already talked about a lot with
the social media and many people waiting
for it
how did you feel i was surprised
that there was a beautiful graphics with
the dots what is great about the against
society is there and it's even greater
i was impressed i got the goosebumps
so you know you bought playstation and
played
against osu godan there are many people
who played
against
you know it is about the visiting your
memory right but uh
uh
so
daikansan said uh you know he said that
he is doing something new
so maybe he was talking about the sixth
one
so what is the perspective of konami you
have a bad impression
okay anyway we have more to come so the
next one is the last vtr
okay so please take a look at the video
clip for eat football
okay so this area is next to ugo area e
football area
so this is a special area
so if you
join this match with winners you can get
this original winner's uniform
at the booth
we have
the
photo taking area
to make an original card for e-football
okay so please come here and enjoy it
of this tokyo game show
so we can experience much with winners
it's a great opportunity for us by the
way ocean
i believe you have additional
information
yes i'm going to show you a video creep
for 2023
[Music]
[Music]
oh i'm coming home
[Music]
yes i am
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is lovely from him
together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
so we're going to make an announcement
of the event which will be launched in
uh
in the future
so oh we have all the very popular
winners torque so please take a look
and then
so next one is powerful pro baseball so
1pm on sunday there will be a stage of
april 2022
the high school
student singer
and also
there will be an exhibition match
between kagami hayato the winner of 2021
and disagree esta the winner of 2022
there will be exhibition match of ninja
sanji question championship you'll need
a ticket and after
the the venue open on 18th cat will be
distributed so please come and get the
tickets and please do wear on them masks
and please refrain from speaking
when you are watching a match
thank you
and there was a new announcement on 15th
about momotaro
right
edition
japan is interesting country it is said
mammoth is a great game to study
geography local specialty social studies
and history
and
this is the new
the game that you can play with the web
browser and tablet and you can use that
in a school study
and you can set the visions and also
teachers can use the game
so
you enjoy and you study
and there will be a geographical
information display function and when
trying stops at the station
and you will set up you will see the
basic information
in order to avoid troubles among kids
you cannot attack someone
targeting
somebody and first in a series there is
no god of poverty
so that
the money you have do not fluctuate too
much so you don't have to worry
it does not cause troubles among
children and there will be a testing
among the uh the schools and it will be
released and we have a message from uh
right yes
so uh he said that he had a dream
to make kamamote
education material so this is the dream
come true so let's get a perfect score
in a geography test and let's make
teachers feel awkward
okay that's great so we have the uh
the website
and uh you can get the inquiry and it
will be introduced free of charge for
the school so please look at that teaser
site
there was an announcement for the title
which is sydney all guns raising so i'd
like to show you this video quick
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is the shooting
game which we are addressing with the
scottish products pro studio kill works
and which will be on sale in 2023 and
also you can enjoy the great music and
also you can you may have the tactics
like offense and defense in enjoying
this shooting
so uh so don't miss it and then i like
to
[Music]
um
high school students who really want to
learn about esports and this school is
operated by gaming company konami and
the students can learn about its sports
and also together with the professional
esports teams and we invite teachers
from there and those professional
teachers will train about strategy
aesthetics of technique and practice and
also these are our lecturers from the
definition and gaming we have levison
who is football uh players and also a
resilient son
for the fortnight and also
we we're going to use the
correspondence school curriculum from
the hga high school so you can get the
diploma of high school and at the end of
the year you can join the trial
to join the professional esports team
and last year two school two to two
students passed the trial so you can you
can see the gaming and esports and
events and a good facility and you can
learn about esports more so please check
the official website
and then i'm going to show you another
video who are the interviews of the
shooting
foreign
[Music]
i can do
so looking at these students they still
really enjoying this
so
please think about that
by the way you have additional
information yes in october we're going
to have the open campus
so if you are interested in there please
come here and also go to the open campus
uh if you say i sell this program you
can get the original clear file so
please join this open campus
i needed more time there was a lot of
things i wanted to say
but it means that there are a lot to
enjoy and you will get to enjoy that in
tokyo game show so please do visit tokyo
gaming show and enjoy konami booth
so alison there are a lot of things
people can enjoy
and just like she said you know people
will get
together
that has been very special i mean we
couldn't get together so it is very
special right
yes
you visit and you enjoy the time
together you can take pictures and it's
how you can enjoy the event
and there are a number of stages and
there are actors voice actors and
producers you cannot get to hear the
stories from them and we have to worry
about typhoon
but uh please be prepared
and please
come and join the booth
and please
have a good plan
so towards autumn uh winter and and
spring you will get more information new
information
so please
come and visit
goodbye everybody thank you for joining
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you